das Tagesgespräch bei Phoenix mit
Matthias Platzeck dem ehemaligen
Ministerpräsidenten und SPD-Chef
Vorsitzende des deutsch-russischen
Forums ich grüße Sie ganz herzlich in
fleetstegelitz
grüß Dich guten Morgen Herr Kulle guten
Morgen blinken und love auf heute
zusammen was kann der bestenfalls
rauskommen außer Sie haben miteinander
geredet
also bestenfalls und ich hoffe auch
weiterhin darauf könnte vereinbart
werden dass jetzt länger geredet wird
Herr Kollege das ist wirklich der Beginn
ist eines
Verhandlungsprozesses wir müssen uns aus
meiner Sicht auf Jahre einstellen denn
da sehr viel kaputt gegangen aber das
wäre es das Signal was das Maximum
wahrscheinlich heute wäre dass man nicht
aufhört miteinander zu reden sondern
dass man vielleicht ein paar Eckpunkte
festzurrt und sagt in diesem Formaten
und in dieser Abfolge werden wir
miteinander jetzt reden und gilt diese
alte Spruch da haben wir uns ja in der
Woche schon oft dran aufgehalten solange
geredet wird wird hoffentlich nicht
geschossen und vielleicht kann man sich
Herr Kuller als Ziel manchmal braucht
man ja solche Ziele setzen
2025 jährt sich zum 50 mal die
Sicherheitskonferenz von Helsinki die
Konferenz für Sicherheit und
Zusammenarbeit die damals dem Frieden
zum ersten Mal seit dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg ein Fundament gegeben hat und
vielleicht kann man sich diese Wegmarke
vornehmen und sagen uns die nächsten
Jahre nutzen um dann eine einigermaßen
stabile Friedensordnung auch wieder
hinbekommen zu haben ja ich freue mich
über Ihren Zuversicht sie haben es
gerade schon gesagt dass einiges kaputt
gegangen vielleicht fangen wir damit an
was ist kaputt
Herr Kolle
dieser Prozess wenn man sich mal die 30
Jahre vornimmt um die geht es ja im
Prinzip jetzt wir haben 1990/91 ich
erinnere an die Karte von Paris waren
wir voller Hoffnung Frieden für immer
war versprochen heute ist das Gegenteil
der Fall die Schuld weisen wir fast zu
100% den Russen zu man muss ja nach
ehrlichen Analyse und eine Analyse
gehört dazu wenn wir dann gute
Schlussfolgerungen ziehen wollen sagen
auch wir im Westen jetzt mal
zusammengefasst waren nachlässig bis
arrogant haben russische Interessen für
nicht denkbar und nicht möglich gehalten
obwohl wir genau wissen dass solche
großen Länder ich rede ich rede jetzt
mal nicht von Großmächten aber große
Länder auch Interessen haben unser
amerikanischen Verbündeten formulieren
ihre Interessen auch und setzen sie in
Teilen dann auch weltweit durch also wir
hatten uns daran gewöhnt dass die Russen
keine Interessen haben sie haben wieder
welche entwickelt als größtes Land der
Erde und wir haben noch nicht gelernt
damit umzugehen und da ist eine Menge
Geschirr wirklich kaputt gegangen die
Russen haben
ihrer Fehler gemacht und zwar heftige
und das alles muss jetzt wieder durch
kluge Politik und durch weitsichtigen
weitsichtige in Teilen auch mutige
Politik zusammengebunden werden ja ich
sag mal Stichwort Krim Ukraine was will
Vladimir Putin und es darf vielleicht
auch Versagen bei
ich habe die letzte den letzten Teil der
Frage nicht verstanden bei
ich glaube dass das Hauptinteresse eins
ist was schon seit Jahrzehnten
formuliert wird wir haben vielleicht
nicht scharf genug und gut genug
zugehört ich erinnere immer wieder an
die Rede 2001 im Deutschen Bundestag war
ganz klar übrigens vom Beifall aller
Fraktionen begleitet einen Wunsch
geäußert hat bezieht uns in eure
Sicherheitsüberlegungen und eure
Sicherheitsarchitektur auf Augenhöhe
etwas was für Russen immer sehr wichtig
ist auf Augenhöhe mit ein sein Berater
karaganoff hat später in einem Interview
gesagt dieser Wunsch ist gehört worden
beklatscht worden in die Schublade
gelegt worden den Wunsch hat er noch
mehrfach auch mit weder wiederholt wir
haben uns dieser Mühe nicht unterzogen
sondern haben die Formate die Strukturen
die da waren einfach gelassen haben sie
ausgeweitet und wundern uns dass die
Russen sich kann man falsch finden aber
als die russische Sicht sich jetzt
bedrängt fühlen übrigens das solche
Anliegen nichts völlig ungewöhnliches
nichts Außergewöhnliches sind haben
unsere amerikanischen Freunde ja auch
schon mehrfach gesagt als Gottschalk mal
Raketen auf Kuba aufstellen wollte haben
sie gesagt nicht mit uns Raketen so nah
das wollen wir nicht obwohl Kuba ein
anderes Land ist als die USA und Putin
hat neulich nicht ganz falsch gesagt
kämen wir auf die Idee und es wäre
irgendwie denkbar in Mexiko irgendwas zu
installieren dann wäre in den USA der
Teufel los genauso ist es das muss man
nüchtern sehen und lassen Sie mich noch
in letzten Satz zu dem Thema sagen Herr
Kolle Klaus von dohnany hat in ihrem
Sender neulich sehr bedenkenswert aus
meiner Sicht gesagt und er weiß ja nun
was auf der Welt vor sich geht dass
niemand daran denkt auch in den USA
nicht in den nächsten 10 20 Jahren die
Ukraine in die NATO aufzunehmen dann
sollte man sich doch ehrlich machen auch
gegenüber den Freunden und Kollegen in
der Ukraine und ihnen das auch so
deutlich sagen und an alle Kraft darauf
verwenden dass die Ukraine was ich
glaube ich auch viel was glaube ich viel
sinnvoller wäre sich der EU weiter
annähern kann dass da die Bande enger
werden dass die Wirtschaft ins Laufen
kommt dass dieses Land sich erholt das
würde auch die Sicherheit verbessern und
ich glaube das wäre der sinnvollere Weg
als da den Glauben zu nähern irgendwann
würde die Ukraine in die NATO
aufgenommen werden und wir wissen alle
wir tun sowieso nicht und deswegen haben
sie auch Verständnis dafür dass Putin da
solche
riesenbataillone von Truppen versammelt
an der Grenze zu Ukraine und jetzt auch
schon dann ankündigt marinemanöver in
größerem Umfang und vielleicht an
mehreren Stellen der Welt
der Koller auch hier sollten wir einfach
nüchtern bleiben nein ich habe für
Manöver und noch dazu diesen Ausmaßes
nie Verständnis ganz prinzipiell nicht
weil ich glaube das löst nie Probleme
sondern schafft immer welche aber wir
dürfen auch nicht völlig vergessen dass
im Sommer dieses Jahres die NATO im
Osten Europas das größte Manöver seit
1930 Jahren seit 1990 durchgeführt hat
also es ist ja auch nicht nur einseitig
das Militärmanöver durchgeführt werden
da waren 10.000 Soldaten unterwegs also
auch das gehört zur Realität und nein
ich finde es nicht sinnvoll ich finde es
nicht gut aber die russische Sicht auf
diesen Vorgang ist wir haben uns oft was
gewünscht wir haben was gefordert nie
hat uns mit uns jemand geredet jetzt
machen wir so eine truppenkonzentration
und siehe da ein Gespräch nach dem
anderen ein Format nach dem anderen
funktioniert plötzlich wieder das ist
auch die Realität ja und natürlich viele
Drohungen die unterwegs sind von der
einen Seite zur anderen und da sitzt
eine am Gashebel in Moskau und da sitzen
andere am Hebel ob man genau zu den zwei
schaltet oder nicht schaltet wo ist
jetzt eigentlich die Lösung das ist ja
eine das ist ja eine Überlagerung von
verschiedenen Punkten
also erstmal was die Gasversorgung
angeht zwei Bemerkungen nur die Russen
haben auch auf dem Höhepunkt des Kalten
Krieges und bis heute auch in diesem
Jahr alle Lieferverpflichtungen erfüllt
und wenn es immer heißt Nord Stream 2
als Hebel zu nehmen ich glaube sollten
die Russen in die Ukraine einmarschieren
sollte der Krieg beginnen dann ist
meiner Meinung nach Nord Stream 2 das
kleinste Problem was wir haben dann
werden wir vor ganz anderen Problemen in
dieser Welt stehen aber sie haben
gefragt welche Lösungsansätze könnte man
könnte man nehmen ich glaube ich habe
bei Frau beerbak auch so was rausgehört
in der Pressekonferenz erstens diese
Sicherheitsbedürfnisse diese
Sicherheitsaspekte und Fragen der Russen
wirklich ernst und Aufnehmen darüber
auch reden ohne dass man sagen könnte
das geht auch gar nicht dass die Wünsche
die sie haben alle erfüllbar wären
zweitens ich weiß dass das ein sehr
schwieriger Vorstellung ist aber wir
sollten uns aus solchen Problemen mal
widmen die krim-frage würde ich aus
diesem verhandlungspaket am Anfang
temporär rausnehmen da sie derzeit
Objektiv nicht lös Neues und man sollte
nicht in die Verhandlung Probleme mit
reinnehmen die derzeit einfach nicht
lösbar sind sondern sich den Themen
widmen die eventuell lösbar sind dann
glaube ich würden wir für die Ostukraine
sehr wohl wesentlichen Schritt
weiterkommen dann könnten wir Herr Kulle
mit den Sanktionen runtergehen und dann
glaube ich und das halte ich für
dringend nötig wäre es an der Zeit
wieder engere wirtschaftliche
Verflechtung auch mit den Russen zu
schaffen mehr Kooperation mehr
ökonomische Beziehung weil jede
Abhängigkeit mehr verringert
Kriegsgefahr verringert konfliktgefahr
an der alten Weisheit hat sich nichts
geändert wir sind im Moment eher auf dem
Weg auch durch die Sanktionen alles zu
lösen was es an Verbindungen gibt da
liegt immer eine Gefahr drin oder am
Ende könnte es passieren dass Russland
immer näher an China ran rückt und das
ist etwas was ich für die Zukunft
unseres Kontinents eigentlich nicht
erleben möchte weil die Konflikte die
daraus resultieren die würden hier bei
uns stattfinden nicht in Sibirien und
nicht im Mittleren Westen USA zur
Realität gehört nicht nur unsere Sicht
aus dem Westen sondern auch die aus dem
Osten Dankeschön dass sie zwischen
diesen beiden Sichtweisen vermitteln
danke Matthias Platzeck
danke Ihnen auch einen guten Tag danke
gleichfalls